so cesium it's a very reactive alkali
metal sort of getting on down in the
periodic table gotta be very careful
it's easy it's very very reactive it's
very very expensive as well and when
you're trying to buy it you got to be
very careful because there's a couple of
different spellings you see on our box
here we got cesium with an A cesium is
one of the heaviest alkali metals the
alkali metals of the elements like
sodium potassium in Group one of the
periodic table and sometimes it's spelt
without an A and in fact the are you
pack spelling is without an A but I
prefer to use this because I think it's
a little bit more novel and a little bit
nicer so this is like you say this is
like a careful box then now we're going
to open the box and you'll see that
inside the foam padding is a glass
ampule of the cesium itself and you can
see that the cesium is a wonderful gold
color okay and you can see this is
sealed in a glass ampule under an argon
atmosphere because the argon is very
unreactive it's not going to react with
anything and it's stopping the caesium
react with moisture or with any air
okay now the cesium itself is a really
quite fantastic metal because depending
on where you are in the world in the
type of periodic table that you're
looking at sometimes it might actually
be recorded reported as a liquid and
sometimes as as a solid or a typical
metal and that's simply because the
melting point of cesium is about 27
degrees you know so that's really quite
close to room temperature in very many
laboratories and and in very many sort
of environments perhaps I can Spain or
perhaps you know other areas which are
not nice and warm so if I stand here
long enough and I heat the caesium with
my hands which obviously this is body
temperature hopefully we might be able
to see that the caesium itself will melt
so we'll be able to see liquid and solid
caesium okay so you know that the the
caesium itself has already started to
melt so you can see that the liquid and
it's starting to become mobile within
the glass itself now we have to be very
very careful when were handling this
because if we break the glass it reacts
very very vigorously with water so the
preparation the sweat on my hands is
enough to make this really quite an
exothermic and a very very dangerous
chemical to work with caesium
because it's at the bottom the period of
the table has very large atoms and this
gives rather interesting properties to
the materials made out of cesium so the
cesium itself is very very expensive as
well our conservative estimate is that
this sample is worth somewhere between
1,000 and 1,500 pounds here is a really
battered piece of cesium bromide and you
can actually bend it can you see I can
bend this where this stuff is so brittle
and the bending is caused or the fact
that you can bend it is caused by the
fact that the atoms are much bigger
cesium and bromine of both loves so you
can see and if you press hard we should
be able to make it go flat again so
there it's restored and the reason I've
got this material is that cesium bromide
is a very good material for letting
through infrared light because the atoms
are large they vibrate very slowly so
you can and they don't absorb infrared
light strongly now we'll put the cesium
back in its box very safely
I'd love to do the experiment where we
put it in water shucks